gnarrk and now it's time for how to be a
pirate
coming from dead stars pub kings me
mateys
Black Dog build some pull me but only
what the drug cuz my real name is Howard
annoying here at that teach a howl puppy
up pilot isn't that right class today
yeah we're gonna be looking at penance
penance thing I'm perfect without the
parrot is like Sarah Palin not wanting
media attention in conceal air a pirate
has had a parrot at some point of every
paratus and the pirate at some point
except for singers are jack monkey who
had himself a singing naked Indian that
was weird
but needless to say a parrot is an
important part to any pirate accessories
you smell like the devil's balls one
hell of a boring speaker - man so
dollies put more people to sleep in a
Catholic Church
love anyway the most important thing
about your parrot is to keep them on
your shoulder foolish little fella
complain away all the time I guess he
doesn't like the smell of bacon and ass
hey so we put some reason you have a
hard time keeping your parrot there
there's two options you can either train
of everything get to know his psyche
until you two are the best of friends or
you can use button I use duct tape he
won't be going anywhere
if that amazing can't can your face or
just your face a woman's as sharp as ice
cream incidentally this little fellas
name is one big bump
I got him cheap at parrots another
things the other things were whores
he didn't cost me much either and he can
say so many various things come Bob Joe
when I touch it alright chevre my temper
eyes hey bull yo what's up all right Bob
what a cracker you think we should blow
the man down blow the man down
I see so many wonderful thing death to
the Blatt I don't know why he says that
it's only once in a while and to be
honest I think that's why I got a bed a
disco shut up he can't help it this
healthy was raised
isn't that right Jenna thank you or the
anus of longshore bastard couldn't get
enough I defeat right man so small he
could use a Cheeto as a battering ram
but seriously if you just overlook that
one incredibly racist comment you'll
find that he's a very very nice man the
skinheads were right okay that one's me
seriously I'm telling you for real
there's no cause for alarm
he's actually a very very kind and
obliterate that you know buddy I say
bubbly tell them about what we did last
night remember that's fighting less than
we saw over there by the water right say
honey would you like a Jolly Roger he's
always the pits and things that you hear
other people say that's $30 a minute bub
okay okay that's enough if you want a
spanking that costs extra
big wave all right if you make people
watch they have to pay too Bob oh my god
that's the tiniest thing I've ever seen
okay you're on thin ice ball do you
seriously please women with that thing
that's where the never have all right
let me guess you can't get it up so I
think it's tiny we say goodbye till one
beep once you stop crying we'll try
again
hey cook here's some real meat white
meat wolf you just can't give good
parents anymore I'm calling that one the
talk for booze hanks although you can
play tetherball back
they act like they see to me but in
reality they love me for I ignore the
tales of blood beard
oh god beer Joe
can I tell you about that golly that's
my little liberal livable at the beard
show they say blood beer joel needs no
gun to kill after he's done shaving heat
refuses the strands of his beard as
throwing daggers
they see that Bloods beard Joel trees
and Optimus Prime by making loved one to
a pickup truck
why wouldn't he make love to a pickup
truck
they say bald the beard Joel created by
Linc's but by passing a kidney stone
blood of the beard Joel could give
himself a vasectomy that and still be
more of a man than any of you the
Titanic was sunk by an iceberg but the
reality was blood beer job justice they
see that the Bloods beer Joe is so
strong and that when he stuffs his foot
the earth splits in half they say that
there was a hammer a fight between chuck
norris
arnold schwarzenegger bruce campbell
blood the bear joe would still win
somehow blood beer jaws teeth are so
mighty that he could make a fortune just
chewing gold and spitting out pieces of
it they say that blood beer Joe once
pointed his gun at the mornin fired
so why like everyone Chinese a glass top
alot the beard soul she may not be God
oh wait yes yes join me next time for
how to be a pilot see you soon this war
is how to be a pirate the greatest show
that of Earth the argh
have you heard stories about the board
the beer Joel I betcha I'll just send it
to this such a nice right here and it
just might make it into the next the
suit but send them quick because by
Yatim quick